Human history is told by the energy we use,
and first we had to use our muscles.
Then we learned to control fire.
We industrialize the world using colon oil and entered the atomic age.
When we learned how to split a nucleus at each step,
we increased our energy harvest to a scale,
never seen before,
and advanced as a species.
Currently,
we're slowly transitioning to renewables and if we're lucky,
fusion energy will become viable in the future as humanity progresses further,
if we don't destroy ourselves or our habitat,
we will locally gain complete control of our planet's resources.
At that stage,
we'll probably begin to look outwards for new places to expand into,
but space is hard and establishing a serious human presence in the solar system
will require ungodly amounts of energy.
Luckily,
we know where to find it.
The Sun,
the ultimate source of energy,
a furnace 100 quintillion times more powerful than our most efficient nuclear
reactor.
It shines with the energy of a trillion nuclear bombs per second.
So how do we get this energy,
not some of us,
all of it.
If we want to collect the most energy physically possible,
we'll have to build the largest,
most ambitious structure in the universe.
The Dysons sphere,
a mega structure that encompasses our whole staff to capture its power output
for an intelligent species.
Building a Dyson sphere is a technological leap on a pile with the discovery of
fire for our ancestors,
the transition from a planetary species to an interstellar species,
it would usher in an age of exploration and expansion on a scale we can barely
imagine.
So what would it look like?
A solid shell enveloping the sun is probably not the way to go.
A large rigid body like that would be vulnerable to impacts,
possibly shattering.
It would be liable to drift and could crash straight into the sun.
A more viable design for a Dyson sphere might be a Dyson swarm and enormous set
of orbiting panels that collect the sun's power and beam it elsewhere,
such as world would give humanity basically unlimited energy.
You've got building,
it won't be easy on the sun is very big,
so we need a lot of satellites.
If each satellite is a square kilometer,
we'd need around 30 quadrillion to surround the summer,
even if they are built as lightly as possible.
We need about 100 quintillion tons of material and then we need the energy to
actually put the parts together and deliver them to their positions around the
sun.
On top of all that,
we need to have a permanent infrastructure set up in space to start building.
Let's assume for the of this video that our descendants will take care of that
and want to create the mega structure.
We can sort the challenges into three main categories,
materials,
design that and energy to get the vast amounts of raw materials required for our
Dyson's swarm will have to largely disassemble a whole planet of the planet's
available.
Mercury is the best candidate.
It's the closest to the sun and very metal rich close to the sun also means less
moving stuff around and mercury has no atmosphere and only about a third of the
surface gravity of earth making it comparatively easy to launch material into
space.
Next,
we should consider the design of our swarm.
Simpler is better.
Conventional solar panels are far too intricate and short lives.
Our satellites need to operate without repairs or intervention for
astronomically long times,
and they need to be cheap to produce.
They're most likely going to be enormous mirrors,
which we focus sunlight to central collecting stations like in concentrated
solar power on earth to build and launch them efficiently.
They must be incredibly light made of little more than polished metal foil,
bound to some supports and lost.
We need the energy to build and launch the swarm itself.
Taking apart a planet and launching things into space requires an enormous
amount of energy.
For example,
if we used all the fossil fuels and uranium on earth and we were perfectly
efficient,
we could only launch as much mass as Mount Everest into space or rather meager
accomplishment compared to penetrate disassembly.
To get the energy needed to build a Dyson sphere,
it's almost as if you're going to need the power output of a Dyson sphere,
but that's okay.
There's plenty of sunlight to be had on mercury,
so let's get to work.
Humans are expensive to keep alive and a very sensitive to the environment.
So we'd want to automate as much as possible.
Ideally,
we'd have a small crew of controllers who oversee an army of autonomous machines
doing the actual work.
There are four major pieces of technology,
requires solar collectors,
minors,
refiners,
and launch equipment.
The solar collectors are going to give us the energy we need to disassemble the
planet to start,
maybe we deploy something like one square kilometer of them pie there as mirrors
or as traditional solar panels.
They'll provide the energy to run our minors,
which strip mined the surface of the Panisse and our refiners,
which extract valuable elements and fabricate them into our swarm satellites to
get them into space.
We need a creative and efficient solution.
Rockets are too expensive and difficult to deal Beta and reuse.
Instead,
we'll want to use a sort of rail Guernica along that electromagnetic track,
which launches our satellites at high speeds.
Our swarms satellites would be packed tight for launch unfurling like an
enormous origami once in always.
From this point,
we can take advantage of exponential growth using the energy of the existing
parts of the swarm to build more infrastructure on mercury and launched new
panels and faster and faster.
Each panel provides the energy to build another.
Those two work together to build the next two four become eight,
eight become 16 and so on.
Within just about 60 doubling times,
the sun would be completely surrounded by solar panels and this can happen
quickly if a square kilometer of so to collectors takes a month to build.
We could be done in a decade if only our infrastructure on the planet's surface
can keep up with a quickly growing budget of energy.
Even collecting 1% of the sun's energy is an unbelievable change in our species
energy budget.
We could create the infrastructure to being basically unlimited amounts of
energy around the solar system for all sorts of projects,
colonies on other worlds,
terraforming planets,
constructing more mega structures or even traveling to other stars.
It could be the start of an interstellar civilizations based on physics alone.
This is not just possible but easy.
It's such a simple process and such a necessary step for any species to expand
beyond our home planet.
That many astronomers that think there are probably Dyson's fairs already out
there in the Milky Way.
We haven't spotted any yet,
but they could be there.
It's far from certain that humanity will ever get to this point.
Our attention is too often focused on short term political gains and conflicts.
That will not matter in the long run,
but if we survive the challenges we've set ourselves,
we could potentially become the first species in the universe to create a
structure with the scope of a star.
If we do it the only limitation left,
we'll be our own imagination.
We've just hit you with a lot of pretty wild claims and crazy concepts.
If you're like us and enjoy using the power of science to determine absurd ways
to destroy stuff,
you might want to hear how you can come up with something like that yourself.
Brilliant is a problem solving website that helps you learn stuff through fun
puzzles that spit up a complex problem into bite size chunks and build up to an
interesting conclusion.
It helps you understand how science works by actually using it instead of just
memorizing a bunch of stuff.
Brilliance has tons of interesting courses and puzzles on things like quantum
computing,
astronomy and logic,
and even Dyson's fares.
If you visit brilliant.org/nutshell or click the link in the description,
you can sign up for free and learn all kinds of things.
As a bonus for quilts cause out viewers,
the first 688 people will also get 20% off that annual membership.
With brilliance.
You can finish each day a little bit smarter and just maybe you can help to
expand the human species into the universe one day.
We love Dyson's spheres so much,
but we've also made a poster about them.
It will look pretty on your wall,
but also has some information about the concept of a Dyson sphere.
A great way to start a conversation or you can just stare at it and dream about
the future.
Go get it here.